we've been talking recently about the
improving numbers when it comes to covid
vaccine hesitancy
some months ago i months ago at this
point almost a year
back in may uh we had somewhere between
two-thirds and three-quarters of
americans hesitant about getting a
coronavirus vaccine
when it becomes available vaccines now
are available we have two vaccines
available a third one coming soon maybe
a fourth one coming soon
and the good news is that the vaccine uh
hesitancy
has declined as far as the covet vaccine
is concerned it got down to fifty
percent
forty percent now about one third of
americans
say they definitely or probably will not
get the covet vaccine according to the
latest poll now
it's good that the hesitancy has
declined
but unfortunately especially when you're
not going to start vaccinating kids
for some period of time in order to get
hurt immunity particularly with these
more
contagious variants you need to have
close to every adult in the united
states vaccinated to get to herd
immunity so
it's still a disaster that one-third of
americans aren't interested but this new
poll did something interesting
which is it actually broke down a
variety of groups political groups
racial groups based on education level
and we have identified
the most anti-coveted vaccine groups in
the country and
three of these groups are republicans
those without a college degree and black
americans these are three
of the most anti-vaccine groups in the
united states
for different reasons importantly and
and members of these different
communities will have different reasons
for telling you
uh why they are skeptical of the vaccine
now
the reasons that people tend to cite as
to why they
don't plan to get the coronavirus
vaccine include concerns about
side effects not trusting
the vaccines from a safety standpoint
and not believing that they need the
vaccine
not trusting the government is another
reason and not knowing that the vaccine
not believing that the vaccine is
actually
effective so let's look at some of the
numbers here
black americans are significantly less
likely than white americans
to want the vaccine 57
of black americans say they want the
vaccine compared to 68
of white americans um hispanic americans
very similar to white americans
in that uh in that category now this to
some degree
is probably related to uh historical
uh um atrocities um
that uh include medical experimentation
uh with black americans and a lot of my
uh black facebook friends have been
posting
a lot about guys while we understand
the historical atrocities related to
experimentation uh we need this vaccine
and what we don't want
is for our community this is not not me
speaking but some of my black friends on
facebook
saying we don't want our community to
end up disproportionately unvaccinated
that will continue
uh to perpetuate these um unequal
outcomes when it comes to
vaccination when it comes to education
americans without college degrees
significantly more likely than
college-educated americans
to um not want the vaccine 40 percent of
those without college degrees
say no vaccine for me only 17 of those
with college degrees say no vaccine for
me so
that's not surprising lack of education
and lack of just a real understanding of
how the vaccine works etc makes perfect
sense that the the the less educated you
are
uh the less able to sort of parse the
scientific data or even know where to
get it that that makes perfect sense not
surprising
and then of course republicans more
likely than democrats and independents
not to want the vaccine and that one is
pretty obvious
when you have had a party that from day
one
led by donald trump starting in when
when was it right january february
um played down the risk of the vaccine
of the uh coronavirus
um played up this idea of it's just the
flu played up the idea of it's going
away soon played up the idea of that's
that's in china it's not going to go
elsewhere and of course we know that all
of those things were wrong
it makes sense that if you were part of
the political party that
that not only spread those ideas but
actually
tried to use them um to justify
re-elections and that failed at least
for donald trump it makes sense that you
would be
less likely to want the vaccine why
would you need a vaccine against
something
that your party leaders have been
telling you for a year now
is really not that serious in the end so
completely unsurprising as far as that
goes now
at some point we have to decide
um what are we going to do
if a significant portion of the
population never
gets vaccinated i do think that uh
various types of businesses saying if
you want to
go to concerts we organize you'll have
to
have proof of vaccination you don't have
to get it the government's not making
you get it we're not making you get it
we're just saying
if you want to do business with us a
private business who organizes concerts
or
flies people around or whatever you will
have to choose to go
and get the vaccine i do think that that
will have
an impact but there are lots of people
who just aren't going to get it unless
something significant changes i don't
know what that's going to be at this
point in time
and it's something we'll have to
continue talking about let me know if
you're surprised by any of these numbers
any of these groups that are the most
vaccine hesitant we'll have more about
this on the david pakman show instagram
which you can find
at david pakman show and while you're
there follow me on instagram
at david.pacman as well start your day
and your new year off right with just
egg which is one of our sponsors you've
heard me talk about the importance of
having a diet that is
more heavily plant-based and it's
something i've done
over the last few years i've always
loved eggs so it's great
that there is a delicious plant-based
version of egg with all the protein of
egg that just egg brings with it but
it's made from mung beans so it uses 98
percent less water
and causes 93 percent fewer carbon
emissions than a conventional egg
and just egg cooks and tastes exactly
like a conventional egg i've tried it
for omelets
scrambled eggs french toast banana bread
pad thai anything you'd normally use
eggs for and i actually think if i
cooked something for a friend
without telling them about just egg they
wouldn't even know the difference find
it in the egg
aisle at your grocery store on amazon
prime now
or on instacart and they also have a
frozen version
perfect for breakfast sandwiches just
egg try it out